President Trump will fly to Southwest
Florida this morning to see the
hurricane damage a county official says
eight people died in the Florida Keys
during the deaths were quote both storm
related and due to natural causes
at least 40 people were injured the
Lower Keys were urban made landfall and
Sunday are still blocked off Elaine
Quijano of our streaming network cbsn is
on wind leakey that's near Isla Mirada
Florida Elaine good morning good morning
to you Nora here in the Florida Keys
power running water and Communications
have been virtually non-existent since
Sunday and those conditions along with
sweltering heat and humidity have made
the recovery process more difficult for
both the thousands who stayed and the
first responders now here to help about
2,000 National Guard members are in the
keys to help distribute food and water
crowds lined up at this parking lot in
Key West for many it's the first aid
they've received in four days Manuel
Bojorquez spoke with Bobbio Rada they
were running out the shelters we try to
get some last night we could of the
roughly 50,000 homes in the Florida Keys
ninety percent are estimated to be
damaged or destroyed by hurricane Emma
first responders are painstakingly
searching through every one of them
looking for anyone dead or alive in this
case we do it quickly with the dogs and
if they get a hit then we begin the
process of taking the structure apart
and hopefully locating somebody Carlos
kvo is with California Task Force One
the 80 person team including 74 Los
Angeles firefighters has worked for
nearly three straight weeks after
deploying to Texas during hurricane
Harvey the willingness of service that's
what this team is about that's why the
members are here they want to come and
serve yesterday the temperature here in
the keys was 93 degrees with 90%
humidity those are the conditions at
California Task Force One is operating
under they are going island to island
searching for victims meanwhile in the
hardest hit parts of the keys power
been restored to just 10% of the area
restoring running water has also been an
issue because fallen trees have ripped
up pipes in people's yards officials
we've spoken with Nora say recovery
fully could take years here
all right Alain thank you